there was a study that came out just
last week it was a pew study of
journalists and it reported that the
majority of journalists don't believe in
telling two sides of the news anymore
that they view one side as
misinformation it shouldn't be told well
whose opinion is it if it's information
or misinformation
and it said that all news outlets whose
audiences lean left
by two to one don't think they should be
telling both sides of a story and then
it surveyed journalists who worked at
news outlets whose audience leans right
and by then 60 40 it was said that you
should cover two sides of the story so
who's being fair who is being objective
and who is being lopsided
do you think that they know that they're
biased i mean i think you're right when
you said the twitter thing before
twitter sort of unmasked it because then
every minute of every day they were
sharing their opinions and then over
time you know you could aggregate it and
go okay you guys obviously have a
certain point of view but i look at a
guy like you know i i hit cnn all the
time on my show jake tapper is always
thought of as the one non-insane guy
there but it's obvious he's a democrat
like do you think that they know what
they're doing or do they think they on
it do you think they honestly believe
they're pulling the wool over our eyes
they know it and i've talked to them
about it they know it a lot of them
privately acknowledge it um but they
won't do anything about it and this is
the problem because they're too
like-minded they're in denial and
they're in decline they're watching
their viewership go down they're
watching their ratings go down they're
watching the trust from the american
people go down but unlike any
corporation who would say when they have
a trend like that what's wrong with us
what do we need to do differently
reporters tend to say what's wrong with
america what do the americans think
differently so what do we do about that
what do we do about that i mean is it
that you know basically the new guy at
cnn just has to fire everybody i mean it
is is it as simple as that does it even
matter anymore i mean should any of us
care we know that the ratings are going
down should we just let them die let
them just go extinct no and here's where
i think i hope my book is a little bit
different i point these things out
because i lament them i want the press
to be fair i want them to be objective
it's so good for america if we can pick
up one source of news and say yep i
believe it i trust it now here's what i
think needs to be done about it without
the media telling us what we're supposed
to think
my solution to it is number one young
people conservatives need to get into
journalism it's healthy number two
journalism schools
newsrooms need to actively recruit
people who think differently journalism
needs a booster shot of independent
thought
and that's not going to come from the
same old people will come from more
conservative thinking people so if i'm a
journalism school if i'm the columbia
school of journalism when i interview
somebody
i would say tell me what your habits are
what are your favorite hobbies and if
somebody says i like to hunt i like to
fish
i enjoy going to church
to me that is a sign of ideological
diversity that i want in my newsroom
these people are so hung up on sexual
orientation or gender or race as opposed
to the most powerful diversity of all
which is diversity of the mind the way
you think
so that's number one journalism schools
need to change conservatives need to go
into j school and then newsrooms and
this is where the cnn experiment is
going to be fascinating the new
leadership of cnn says they want to
return to objectivity i'm going to watch
them i want to see what they do we'll
see
so on on the first point on the schools
i mean i i agree with you but do you
think there's honestly any chance in
high hell that that anyone at columbia
university that's been completely
infected by this woke thing is going to
do it i mean do you think any any
professor of journalism is going to put
their butt on the line to do what you
just said right there yeah probably not
and again i lament it but that's that's
the solution because what's what's the
alternative the alternative is we
continue the trend we're on and here's
what that trend looks like
conservative media is booming
conserving the viewership continues to
go up liberal media it goes down but
it's not healthy for democracy again i
want to be able to pick up one source of
news and say i'm done for the day it
took me 10 minutes i read it i accept it
and here's what we need to do now and
then you debate it in the political
sphere and you actually go to vote and
whoever wins wins the election and moves
the country
but we shouldn't have to as a people
read five sources of news to figure out
what is right and what is wrong and
weigh it and balance it
and i get that question all the time
where can i go and frankly i'll tell you
this too dave the best show on the news
in my opinion is the six o'clock evening
show on fox with bret baer it is
old-fashioned straight down the middle
good reporting it's not cut from the
same liberal cloth but it's not you know
ideological conservative show either
it's just straight reporting and i miss
that i like watching that show so
speaking of fox since you're a fox
contributor and i go on fox a couple
times a week i find fox they never tell
me what to say i say whatever i want
often things that are against say the
general conservative
line um i i'm guessing that they let you
say whatever you want but feel free to
correct that if not but there's a
constant move to take them out i mean
there is a constant move to make sure
that tucker who is the number one cable
news host in the history of television
cannot get advertisers uh how does all
that fit into the the situation we're in
right now remember where that started
remember when barack obama tried to take
out rush limbaugh yeah he went after
rush by name it was a deliberate white
house effort to take down rush and then
they tried to do it to fox look
and this is why i kind of do doubt that
the mainstream media is capable of
fixing itself
they lost their customers the only
reason fox found a home was because
people voted to leave the liberal
mainstream media because they were no
longer being served they recognized how
liberal the media became
and it's kind of like china with taiwan
the mainstream media does not like the
fact that there's a breakaway that
there's one group that thinks
independently that thinks differently
that recognizes that the ways of the
liberal mainstream media are not the
ways of most americans and so they need
to take down fox just like china wants
to reabsorb taiwan
and
again look at the ratings the american
people have rejected what the mainstream
media is doing that's why fox is so
popular they struck a niche they found a
home with an independent different
thought and it can't be stopped
but fox is really alone you have fox you
do talk radio you do podcasts you do
have now have a new type of electronic
front the federalist the daily examiner
things of that nature the daily wire
but again it's the balkanization of
american information
and
i read left right and center
but man i have to work hard to figure
things out again i think it'd be easier
for the american people if we had faith
in one as opposed to have this
balkanization how much of this do you
think is connected to sort of the
progressive takeover of the democrat
party that say when you were press
secretary and as you said you were there
was a little more of a blend of
reporters in there okay
the answer is different but we can
basically agree on the facts that now
you know basically the modern left the
democrat party they don't believe
america is fundamentally decent they
don't seem to believe in our founding
documents or separation of powers or all
of these things so that of course is
then going to leak into the people who
are translating the news to the average
guy and it's even worse in that day
because you have a young generation of
reporters who think their job is to be
subjective not objective they think
there's something wrong with objectivity
there was a study that came out just
last week it was a pew study of
journalists and it reported that the
majority of journalists don't believe in
telling two sides of the news anymore
that they view one side as
misinformation it shouldn't be told well
whose opinion is it if it's information
or misinformation
and it said that all news outlets whose
audiences lean left
by two to one don't think they should be
telling both sides of a story and then
it surveyed journalists who worked at
news outlets whose audience leans right
and by then 60 40 it was said that you
should cover two sides of the story so
who's being fair who is being objective
and who is being lopsided and it it's
this the the takeover of journalism by
these young social warriors which is
what they are
is killing journalism and it happened at
the new york times one of my favorite
parts of the book is what happened when
senator tom cotton wrote
that online for the new york times that
the new york times headlines send in the
troops
and it was in the summer of 2020 after
the george floyd murder and riots were
everywhere 150 federal buildings were
damaged and tom cotton said send in the
troops
a meltdown in the new york times
newsroom young reporters one after
another after another tweeted that this
was violence to them
the violence was in the streets the
violence was with the poor people who
ran mom and pop shops that were being
torn down and looted and destroyed
but it was these people sitting in a
cubicle in manhattan who said this is
violence and they forced the new york
times to tuck its tail to retract the
op-ed to say it never should have been
run in the first place to fire their
editorial page editor reassign the
deputy editorial page editor it was a
purge
it was like a college campus broke out
inside the new york times where the
young people demanded the administration
silence a voice with which they disagree
it was one of the worst most
embarrassing episodes to be a media
organization dedicated to free speech
but free speech didn't stand a chance
against the young social warriors of
journalism if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about the media instead of non-stop
yelling check out our media playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out the full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell